الاتفاق مكن من تصدير نحو ثلاثه وثلاثين
مليون طن من الحبوب منذ بدء تنفيذه مطلع
اغسطس اب عام 2022
اكثر الدول المستفينه المستفيده كانت
الصين باكثر من سبعه ملايين طن ثم اسبانيا
فتركيا وفق مركز التنسيق المشترك في
اسطنبول
برنامج الاغذيه العالميه بدوره تمكن بفضل
الاتفاق من توفير اكثر من 700 الف طن من
القمح لدول تعيش ازمات مثل افغانستان
واثيوبيا وكينيا والصومال والسودان واليمن
معنى من موسكو مراسله الجزيره رانيا دريدي
ومن انقره مراسل الجزيره المعتز
مراسل الجزيره مراد هاشم مرحبا بكم جميعا
وابدا مع رانيا كيف كانت مسوغات الاتفاق
كما جاء على السنه المسؤولين الروس عفوا
مسوغات الغاء او نقط او عدم تمديد الاتفاق
رميه
نعم يعني روسيا واضحه في هذه الجزئيه منذ
البدايه تحدثت كثيرا خلال الاشهر الماضيه
ولا سيما خلال الايام الماضيه عن ان الجزء
الروسي من صفقه الحبوب لا يتم تنفيذه هنا
اود الاشاره بان صفقه الحبوب او ما يسمى
بمبادره البحر الاسود هي
اتفاقيه تضم شاقين الشق الاوكراني المعني
بتصدير الحبوب الذي يتم تنفيذه والشرق
الروسي المعني بتوريد السلع الغذائيه
الروسيه الزراعيه والاسمده الروسيه عبر
رفع العقوبات عن هذه الاسمده والسلع
الزراعيه كي تتمكن روسيا من تصدير هذه
السلع الغذائيه ولكن الشق الروسي لم يتم
تنفيذه بشكل كامل حتى الان حتى الان لم
يتم الرفع العقوبات عن يعني على الخطوط
اللوجستيه عن الموانئ عن السفن عن البنوك
الروسيه المعنيه وبالتالي روسيا ترى ان في
اطار الاتفاق لا يتم تنفيذ ما تم التوصل
اليه ما بين روسيا والامم المتحده في هذا
في هذه الجزئيه هذه النقطه النقطه الاخرى
وهي ان صفقه الحبوب كان هدفها انساني
بالدرجه الاولى اي ضمان وصول الحبوب الى
الدول الاكثر فقرا الى الدول الافريقيه
على سبيل المثال ولكن بحسب الجانب الروسي
جزء صغير جدا من هذه الحبوب يذهب الى
الدول الفقيره وبالتالي
الهدفان الاساسيان اللذان يعني مهمان
بالنسبه لروسيا الذي دفعهما لي دفعتهما
لتوقيع هذه الاتفاقيه لم يتم تنفيذهما
وبالتالي روسيا لا ترى حتى هذه اللحظه
وجود اي مبررات للاستمرار في هذه الصفقه
اليوم الناطق باسم الخارجي ماريا زخارب
اعلنت انه تم ابلاغ كل من الامم المتحده
الجانب الاوكراني الجانب التركي بتعليق
العمل بهذه الصفقه ولكن ذلك روسيا لا تزال
تبقي الباب مفتوحا امام العوده لهذه
الصفقه ولكن بالطبع شريطه تنفيذ الشروط
الروسيه في اطار الاتفاقات التي تم التوصل
اليها والتي لم يتم تنفيذها حتى هذه
اللحظه اذا روسيا واضحه وهذا قرار هو قرار
كان متوقع وود الاشاره الى ايضا تصريح في
غايه الاهميه فيما يتعلق بربط هذه تعليق
هذه الصفقه باحداث جسر القرن تعرض جسر
القرن لهجوم وصفتهم موسكو بالارهابي في
هذا الاطار اليوم الكرملين نفى كل ما صدر
من ادعائك بان روسيا اتخذت هذا القرار على
خلفيه الهجوم الذي تعرض له جسر الكرم اشار
الى ان القرار تم اتخاذه مسبقا في هذه
الجزئيه وان الرئيس الروسي كان قد افصح
بشكل مفصل عن موقف موسكو في هذا الاطار
دعينا ننتقل الى المعتز بالله حسن من
انقره المعتز بالله هذا التركيه كانت
الوسيط الرئيسيه في هذه الاتفاق يه حتى ان
الرئيس اردوغان بنفسه تحدث عن هذا الموضوع
وعلق عليه وليس مجرد احد من المتحدثين هل
عبر الرئيس اردوغان عن رؤيه محدده لعوده
روسيا او حمل عوده روسيا على الاتفاق مره
اخرى
بالتاكيد محمود تعتبر تركيا ان النجاح
صفقه الحبوب كان هو جزء من الدور
الاستراتيجي الذي لعبته تركيا في سياستها
الخارجيه خصوصا فيما يتعلق بالحرب الروسيه
الاوكرانيه الاتراك يقولون ان هذه
الاتفاقيه كانت جزءا من تامين الغذاء
للكثير من الذين يحتاجونه الاتراك ايضا
تحدثوا سابقا عن انه يجب ان يتم تحقيق
الشق المتعلق بالروس ايضا من هذه
الاتفاقيه وذلك في شعله سعيهم بان يكونوا
وسيطا محايدا كما تعلم مراد لم يستطع ربما
كثيرون حاولوا في هذا الملف ان يتوصلوا
الى حل وتحقيق هذه الاتفاقيه ونجحت تركيا
مع الامم المتحده في ذلك لدورها وموقعها
بين الدولتين الان فيما يتعلق بالموقف
التركي الحالي الرئيس التركي رجب طيب
اردوغان اليوم في المؤتمر الصحفي الذي سبق
زياره خليجيه يقوم بها هو قال انه سيواصل
لجهوده في هذا الاطار وان الهيئه الخاصه
الهيئه التركيه الخاصه بهذا الملف يتواصل
اتصالاتها وهو يقول انه بعد عودته من هذه
الزياره الخارجيه سيكثف ايضا اتصالاته مع
الجانب الروسي من اجل العوده عن هذا
القرار بحسب الرئيس التركي هو يعتقد ان
الرئيس الروسي هو يريد المضيف هذه
الاتفاقية ولكن ايضا هو يقول اي الرئيس
التركي انه قد لا ينتظر الى موعد الزياره
المرتقبه التي يمكن ان يقوم بها الرئيس
فلاديمير بوتين الى تركيا وانما سيبدا
اتصالاته فورا بعد عودته من زيارته
الخارجيه الى دول الخليج لان هذا الملف هو
مهم لتركيا كما هو مهم للدول التي تستفيد
من هذه الصفقه خصوصا واننا نتحدث عن 32
مليون طن تم اخراجها من الحبوب خلال هذا
العام وان كنا شهدنا تراجعا في هذا الرقم
في شهر يوليو الحالي حيث سجل فقط 230 الف
طن وهذا كان مؤشرا على ان هذه الصفقه قد
تؤول الى مالت اليه اليوم من اعلان روسي
وبالتالي سيكون هناك سعي في الايام
المقبله من الجانب التركي
للضغط باتجاه ان تعود كل من روسيا
واوكرانيا الى هذا الاتفاق